can you tell the story of this boy W
alom he's a six-year-old Palestinian
American boy who was stabbed 26 times in
his home in planfield Township Illinois
it was found to be a hate crime
motivated by
islamophobia and
um the
attacker said you Muslims must
die so before before W was killed W was
killed on a Saturday it was um the
immediate Saturday after October 7th I
remember on
Friday uh media starts to reach out to
every Imam in the country every Muslim
leader in the country and say what are
you going to do about this Global day of
jihad what are you going to do about the
global day of jihad it's like what are
you talking about it's like well Hamas
has called for a global day of jihad so
how are you going to stop Muslims from
attacking people right so it's Friday
and I'm like well this is the first I'm
hearing from you and I I remember
responding to a local reporter most
people I just ignored I responded to a
local reporter I said I've got people in
my community that have already lost 10
15 relatives at that point now it's
2030 and you haven't said a word and now
you're reaching out to me about the
potential violence of Muslims in America
this is great this is just like 911
right what are you going to do to
restrain you angry
Muslims from responding to what's
happening overseas and responding to the
call of a global day of jihad guess what
that
night this man takes out a military
knife and attacks a six-year-old boy a
six-year-old Palestinian Boy by the way
it gets worse the more details that you
know and and I recently had a chance to
go and speak to his mom uh cuz she was
in the hospital when I was there for the
funeral so I had a chance to visit her
um not too long ago and she was attacked
also she was attacked first it was
actually their landlord so Hanan the
mother um was at home with wadir
six-year-old
boy landlord comes in and with
absolutely no emotion just charges at
her starts with her she was able to
fight him off he stabbed her initially
seven or eight times with a military
grade
knife she fought him off um escaped to
call 91
1 and while she's calling 911 she hears
wadir wad ran up to the man calling him
Uncle
Joe because the landlord prior to that
had been kind to them used to give wer
toys wer had an infectious beautiful
smile every picture you see of that kid
beautiful beautiful beautiful smile and
so w runs up to him says Uncle Joe he
runs up to him to give him a hug even
though he's carrying a military grade
knife with blood on it cuz wer doesn't
believe that harm can come to him from
that
man and um Hanan didn't think
that he would do anything to her kid
even in that fit of rage the last thing
that she says she heard was oh
no you know what says oh no and then he
starts to stab him 26 times says you
Muslims Must Die
uh usually in a scene like that police
are
hesitant to classify something as a hate
crime it was classified as a hate crime
the very same
day the thing is is that who's complicit
in that hate crime what filled that
man's head for him to believe that he
was doing an act of Good by murdering a
six-year-old Palestinian
boy and
reality Uncle Joe was motivated by
President Joe Biden
who repeated a debunked report that
there were 40 beheaded Israeli babies
and he said I saw 40 beheaded Israeli
babies the White House walked it
back afterwards in a statement that no
one reads because it was factually false
but Uncle Joe heard
it and had been binge
watching media about these violent
Palestinians and suddenly the propag
Ganda overcame his own humanity and what
he knew of that family and he went in
and ruined their lives and you know now
you know just like any any
mom you know she hasn't moved the thing
his bike is still in the same place it
was toys are still in the same place
she's left with this great void this
great emptiness if that was the only
crime it would be
enough to wake this country up and say
oh no this is not where we need to go oh
no right the last thing she heard him
say was oh no if that was it and I got
the news by the way when I was
ironically at a protest we were
protesting on Saturday Downtown Dallas
and I started getting all these texts
about what happened in Chicago oh no
right
like no Muslims attacked anyone the
media was in a frenzy over the global
day of jihad I got called by national
news outlets and local news outlets what
are you going to do about musl Muslims
that are going to turn into monsters and
start killing people in the streets next
thing we know we have a dead
six-year-old Palestinian boy went to his
funeral um and that's kind of speaks to
the proximity part of
things yeah it felt like stepping into
Gaza right for a moment it didn't feel
like America didn't feel like America
felt like stepping into Gaza his casket
was wrapped in a Palestinian flag
um there was not just sadness at his
funeral but a deep sense of anger at the
funeral some of his family members
shouted out Joe Biden you did this Joe
Biden you did
this
um and and you know I
remember the next day it was right after
the
funeral looking at the front page of
CNN and the story of wer was buried in
the last in the last
section and it was right over all these
meaningless ads and I thought to myself
that's it like if this was if this was
an Arab man let's be real let's be
honest here if this was a Palestinian
landlord that stabbed a six-year-old
Jewish boy to
death this would have gotten more
attention it would have been the front
page of the news and rightfully so
people would have grieved over over the
insanity of stabbing a 6-year-old boy 26
times became an afterthought the very
next
day and so it's an extension of the
bigotry an extension of the racism and
there's so much that happens after that
there's the terrible uh stabbing of uh
Detroit synagogue president Samantha
wall and it's horrible she was stabbed
in her driveway immediately front page
of all the news out immediately it's the
main news story and immediately the
implications are there go the Muslims
the Palestinians have lost their minds
the Muslims have they are who we thought
they were right that's what it is they
are who we thought they were they went
and they stabbed a synagogue president
it turned out it wasn't a hate crime
although it's an awful crime it turned
out it wasn't a hate crime what dear's
an afterthought had people reach out to
me
afterwards expressing
condolences and I responded to them
those who have Justified the genocide in
Gaza but that Were Somehow offering
condolences uh for wer privately of
course you know by the way if a Muslim
would have committed that crime every
single Muslim leader would have had
press in front of their door to condemn
that crime we would have all been made
complicit I had people reach out to me
say I'm sorry about what happened with
with wer it's terrible you know I saw
you at the funeral praying for you my
response was what's the between wadir
and a boy in Gaza what's the difference
between me and wad I'm a Palestinian
child my parents made it out of
Palestine I was born in this country if
I didn't have the opportunity to grow up
here and to become the person that I
became you would have been justifying my
murder right now you would have been
okay with my genocide you would have
been giving the talking points to the
press to erase me but you feel sorry
because wadir was killed and I think
this is when we say that and anti
Palestinian bigotry is an extension of
islamophobia if a mosque gets targeted
here people rightfully rush to protect
that mosque and say this is horrible and
it shouldn't happen but when you have an
Israeli soldier bombing a mosque and
laughing like a maniac on video and it's
going viral on Tik Tok and there is no
way to reain that in and you don't have
a word of condemnation about it in fact
you are standing in the way of a
ceasefire then you're a hypocrite
there's no way around it you are a hyp
hypocrite what's the difference between
a mosque here and a mosque there what's
the difference between a Palestinian
life here and a Palestinian life there
if you're okay with me being murdered
there don't say that you care about my
life here and so that hypocrisy has been
laid bare we have said multiple times
masks are falling masks are falling
people that we thought were decent
people somehow have found it in
themselves to justify a
genocide there is no shortage at this
point of video and again when you you
know I could have made the excuse for
you maybe in the first few
weeks you know that you hadn't seen
enough but with all social media
suppression across all platforms there
isn't a single platform that hasn't
suppressed Palestinian voices with all
that
suppression there are enough videos at
this point of children whose heads have
been blown off of children walking
around without limbs of parents carrying
their their kids in bags not body bags I
mean grocery bags cuz they don't even
have body bags and screaming out and
saying why are you doing this to me make
it stop and you come back and you tell
that
person hamas's
fault where is your Humanity where is
your sense of decency isn't that the
logic of the so-called terrorism that
you condemn yeah you can wipe out entire
populations you should have talked to
Hamas tomas's fault all the kids in the
West Bank all
like where where does this end so what's
your what what are your moral boundaries
here right so if if that's the logic
that you're okay with then in that case
when there's a mass shooter in a school
in the United States just bomb the whole
school in fact bomb the whole town if
you can't find the mass shooter you know
where does this end for you right and so
when I say people have lost their
Humanity they're killing us overseas but
their hearts are dying people have lost
their Humanity they've lost any sense of
morality and their moral boundaries and
being there and and and I mean
participating in his funeral it was it
was anger I'm not used to that I'm not
used to that you know I'm an Imam I
Pastor to people I went to Christ Church
and that was the worst I'd ever seen
before where 50 Muslims were killed by a
white
supremacist and he murdered them with
such callousness and I remember being at
those funerals and and yeah I mean there
was anger but it was just profound
sadness because at least the rest of the
world could all come out in one voice
and say that's
wrong now most of the world sees what's
happening in Gaza and says this is
disgusting most of the world sees this
and says this is a
genocide but we happen to live in this
bubble here where we're constantly being
told we did this to
ourselves and that's the same logic that
led to our initial expulsion
1948 what was the crime of those 700,000
Palestinians that were driven out of
their home in 1948 what did they do they
didn't do they did not commit the
Holocaust they didn't have a mass murder
of Jews at their hands what did they do
what crime were they paying
for and so it's been the consistent
theme this is the story of our people
not since October 7th this is the story
of our people for the last 75
years